It is one of the most common, yet
also, one of the most perplexing
sleep disorders that exists.
Insomnia. At any given time, it can
affect around ten percent of the
world’s population, causing
countless hours of lost sleep and
wakeful anguish. But, why does it
happen, and how does one overcome
it? Stay tuned to find out.
Naturally, we fall asleep at night.
It is how the human body reacts to
exhaustion, and it is a part of the
innate biological rhythm which our
species has maintained for
thousands of years.
Yet, more than 30 million Americans
suffer from at least a mild form of
insomnia, that causes them to have
difficulty falling asleep when they
want to, and which subsequently
leads to the suffering of fatigue
and drowsiness during the daytime.
And during their nights, sufferers
of insomnia experience a whole
other set of troubles and pains,
which add to their woes.
What time is it right now?
Quite often, during the late hours
of the night, an insomniac’s mind
will race with activity.
Tomorrow’s gonna be a big day.
Better get some sleep.
Why do I feel like I’m forgetting
something?
Ugh. It’s too quiet in here. I can
hear myself breath.
And, inconveniently enough, many of
their thoughts will be the ones
that induce the most anxiety,
depression, and stress; making it
quite a challenge for the
individual to find any relaxation
right before bed.
This is ridiculous.
There may be a variety of different
reasons which cause these thoughts
to become so prominent at night,
but once they begin, they become
very difficult for insomniacs to
suppress.
And, to make matters worse, some
sufferers will also experience
irritability, discomfort, or even
pain, after lying awake in bed for
a while.
Many who experience persistent
insomnia crave for regular sleep
schedules, and the capacity to fall
asleep comfortably and to wake up
refreshed, but falling into such
routines without relying on the use
of sleeping pills or other types of
drugs can be a tenacious problem
that each individual must often
find their own unique solution to.
For instance, distractions such as
television...
... books, or computers, could
potentially stimulate the mind and
keep an individual awake for much
longer than they desire, or
conversely, they could actually
distract the mind for just long
enough from all the thoughts that
are keeping the individual awake.
It really depends on the person.
The key is to figure out what works
for you, and the best way to do
that is to experiment. If you
suffer from insomnia, finding out
what triggers your brain to send
the signals to the rest of your
body to nod off is the key to
overcoming this disorder.
For some, getting out of bed to do
something relaxing, such as
drinking a warm beverage or reading
a book, can be more helpful than
simply lying awake in bed.
For others, listening to music or
watching a familiar TV show can do
the trick.
It also helps to be mindful of what
environmental conditions are
preferable and conducive to you
falling asleep, such as the amount
of light in the room, how noisy it
is during sleep hours, and the
room’s temperature.
And, it really helps to move all
clocks out of plain view, as this
effectively alleviates the anxiety
associated with watching the night
hours tick away.
The activities that you engage in
before bedtime can also have an
effect on how quickly you might be
able to fall asleep at night. Some
general things to avoid are heavy
late-night meals, vigorous
exercise, and work-related tasks
that might cause stress.
Suffice it to say, big discussions
or arguments should also be avoided
right before bed, and all of these
stressful activities should be
replaced by more soothing ones, in
low lighting conditions if viable.
This will generally prime the mind
and the body for sleep long before
it is time to actually fall asleep.
As for screens such as televisions,
smart phones, and tablets...
Research has shown that the light
emitted from these screens tends to
suppress the body’s production of
melatonin, and that can severely
disrupt sleep patterns, but if you
find that watching something helps,
then it might be a good idea to
stick to what works, and perhaps,
just set things so that these
screens are turned off afterwards.
And, that concludes part 2 of our
12 part series on disturbing sleep
disorders. Insomnia is a widespread
condition with different solutions
for different people, so to
continue the conversation, please
feel free to comment below with
your own experiences on it, and
don’t forget to like and subscribe.
Until next time, good night and
sleep tight.